DELLARRIZATION OF
DENUARRIZATION OF
DENUCLRIZATION OF
DENUCLEAZATION OF
DENUCLEARITION OF
DENUCLEARIZAON OF
DENUCLEARIZATI OF
DENUCLEARIZATIONF
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
PENINSULA.
UNTIL THEN THEY WILL KEEP
THE PRESSURE ON.
SEAN?
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
JOINING ME WITH REACTION
FORMER ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT SEBASTIAN GORKA
AND FORMER SECRET SERVICE
AGENT, NRA TV CONTRIBUTOR
DAN BONGINO.
DR. GORKA, WE START WITH
YOU.
YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY THAT HAS
BEEN SO CRITICAL, OH, ROCKET
MAN.
I CAN ASSURE AND I WILL
ADDRESS THIS IN MY MONOLOGUE
TONIGHT.
I CAN ASSURE THE WORLD THAT
HE IS NOT GOING TO BE
OFFERING $150 BILLION IN
CASH AND OTHER FOREIGN
CURRENCIES.
NOR WILL HE BE OFFERING WHAT
BILL CLINTON GAVE, KIM JONG
UN'S FATHER, KIM IL.
WAS THAT ENERGY AND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
>> IT'S TRULY INCREDIBLE,
SEAN, WHAT A MASSIVE
MAKES.
WHY HAVE
WEY HAVE
WE HHAVE
WE HAVVE
WE HAVEE
WE HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION
KNOT GOING TO KOWTOW TO EVIL
REGIMES OR FUND TERRORIST
REGIMES AS YOU RIGHTLY
POINTED OUT WITH THE DEAL.
AMERICAN SLIP BACK.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO HAS
WALKED THE WALK, TALKED THE
TALK, AND CARRIED A VERY
LARGE STICK.
HE STOOD UP TO THIS
STALINISTIC DICTATORSHIP IN
NORTH KOREA.
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN A MATTER
OF JUST A FEW MONTHS,
THEY'VE BACKED DOWN AND THEY
WANT TO TALK AFTER DECADES
AND DECADES OF APPEASEMENT.
THIS IS THE VINDICATION OF
THE PRESIDENT'S FOREIGN
POLICY.
AFTER THE CRUSHING OF
IDENTIFIES, THIS
ISENTIFIES, THIS
ISISTIFIES, THIS
ISIS,IFIES, THIS
ISIS,THIES, THIS
ISIS,THISS, THIS
ISIS,THIS I THIS
ISIS,THIS ISTHIS
ISIS,THIS IS PIS
ISIS,THIS IS PERHAPS THE BIGGEST
FOREIGN POLICY WIN THAT WE
HAVE SEEN.
IT'S LESS THAN A YEAR AND A
HALF INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT HAS
PLAGUED THE WEST, PLAGUED
THE PACIFIC REGION FOR
DECADES.
FINALLY THERE IS HOPE OF
RESOLUTION.
REMEMBER, WHAT REAGAN SAID,
TRUST BE VERIFY, BUT WE ON
THE WAY TO STABILIZING THE
PENINSULA.
>> Sean: WELL SAID.
DAN BONGINO, BY SHOWING
STRENGTH AND A COMMITMENT,
ONE THING THAT I DON'T THINK
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
UNDERSTOOD IS THE AFFECT,
THE IMPACT, THESE SANCTIONS
HAVE HAD.
CHINA, THE PRESIDENT'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA HAS
PUT A LOT OF PRESSURE.
AND CHINA HAS WITHDRAWN A
LOT OF THEIR FINANCIAL
SUPPORT AND TRADE AS IT
RELATES TO NORTH KOREA.
THAT HAS PLAYED A PART IN
IT.
ALSO, AMERICA'S MILITARY
FORCE IN THE REGION AS SHOWN
BY THE PRESIDENT.
IT WAS NO QUESTION WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES WOULD BE IF KIM
JONG UN CONTINUED WHAT HE
WAS DOING IN FIRING THESE
MISSILES.
HE WAS PRECIPITATING A
CRISIS.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD STRIKE.
IT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
IT WAS INEVITABLE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SEAN, A COUPLE POINTS ON
THIS.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE LESSONS
A LOT OF THESE HOSTILE
GEOPOLITICAL ACTORS LEARNED
AROUND THE WORLD AFTER THE
IRAQ WAR WAS NEVER EVER GO
TO WAR WITH THE UNITED
STATES WITHOUT NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
YOU WILL BE ANNIHILATED AND
ANNIHILATED QUICKLY.
WELL, THE KIM REGIME LEARNED
FROM THAT AND THEY HAVE BEEN
HOLDING THE THREAT OF
NUCLEAR WAR LIKE A GUN TO
THE HEAD OF THE WORLD NOW
FOR YEARS.
BUT THINK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
THEY TOOK ADVANTAGE OF OUR
PREDICTABILITY ON, THIS
SEAN, AND WE HAVE BEEN
PREDICTABLE THROUGH DEMOCRAT
AND REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATIONS.
THEN WE GET A QUEEN'S
BUILDER IN OFFICE WHO DROPS
A COUPLE DEAF CON ONE LEVEL
TWEETS IN THERE.
IS HE ENTIRELY UNPREDICTABLE
AND ALL OF THE SUDDEN THEY
WANT TO CHAT ABOUT
DENUCLEARIZATION.
I THINK TRUMP DESERVES EVEN
FROM LIBERAL HATERS AND
THEY'RE MANY AND LEGION IN
THE MEDIA DESERVES A LITTLE
BIT OF CREDIT FOR WHAT
DR. GORKA SAID AND HE IS
RIGHT A MAJOR, MAJOR FOREIGN
POLICY BREAK THROUGH.
>> Sean: VERY PREDICTABLY
DR. GORKA THE LEFT ONLY
LIKES IT IF WE ARE BOWING
AND KISSING THE RING OF
MURDERING DICTATORS AND
OFFERING BRIBES.
WHILE OFFERING BRIBES WITH
BILL CLINTON AND KIM JONG IL
DIDN'T WORK.
NOT GOING TO WORK WITH THE
MULLAHS IN TEHRAN.
THIS PRESIDENT TOOK A
DIFFERENT RESPONSE.
IT ABSOLUTELY SENT THE MEDIA
IN THIS COUNTRY THEY WERE
APOPLECTIC OVER THE FACT
THAT HE CALLED LITTLE ROCKET
MAN, LITTLE ROCKET MAN.
MAKE FUN OF HIM, YEAH, OUR
WEAPONS ACTUALLY WORK AND WE
HAVE A LOT MORE THAN YOU DO
AND YOU ARE GOING TO PAY A
VERY SEVERE PRICE.
THE ONE CONSISTENT THING
THAT WE SEES A WE LOOK
THROUGH HISTORY IS THAT
CAPITULATION AND APPEASEMENT
NEVER WORKS.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH.
IT'S NOT JUST A SLOGAN.
IT IS A PHILOSOPHY.
AND THE ONLY WAY TO GET
RESPECT IS TO STAND STRONG
IN THE FACE OF TYRANNY.
>> RIGHT.
AS WE DID TWICE DURING THE
20TH CENTURY AND AMERICAN
SAVED WESTERN CIVILIZATION.
SAVED JUDEO-CHRISTIAN JUDEO CIVL
SAVED JUDEO-CHRISTIAN JUDEO CIVZ
SAVED JUDEO-CHRISTIAN JUDEO CIVT
SAVED JUDEO-CHRISTIAN JUDEO CIVO
SAVED JUDEO-CHRISTIAN JUDEO CIVN
FROM THE NAZIS.
I WANT TO SEE "THE
WASHINGTON POST," CNN, ON
THE HUFFINGTON POST THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO EAT CROW
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT'S
POLICIES WORKED.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE REAL
IRONY IS?
GUESS WHO GOT THE NOBEL
PEACE PRIZE IN THE MAN WHO
COMPLAMED OUT WITH HIS
POLICY BARACK OBAMA WHO
DESERVES A PEACE PRIZE RIGHT
NOW?
IT'S DONALD TRUMP FOR WHAT
HE IS BRINGING TO THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: LET ME GO, DAN
BONGINO TO THE ACTUAL
STATEMENT.
I THINK THIS IS REALLY
PROFOUND AND I BROUGHT THIS
UP WITH JOHN ROBERTS.
AND JOHN ROBERTS INSIGHT
INTO THE PRESIDENT.
I'M NOT TRYING TO START A
WAR.
I WANT PEACE HERE.
PEACE DOESN'T BEGIN BY
BEGGING DICTATORS TO BE NICE
TO US.
WE ARE NICE TO YOU AND BRIBE
YOU WILL YOU PLEASE BE NICE
BACK.
THIS IS BIGGER THAN JUST
STOPPING THE NUCLEAR TESTING
AND THE MISSILE TESTING
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON.
THIS IS ABOUT
DENUCLEARIZATION.
AND IN THE MEANTIME, THE
JOINT EXERCISES CONTINUE
WITH SOUTH AMERICA AND OUR
ALLIES.
IN THE MEANTIME, THE
SANCTIONS CONTINUE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN UP
NOTHING.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE LITTLE
ROCKET MAN BLINKED AND
BLINKED BIG TIME TONIGHT
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN WORKING
AND HE SEES THIS AS A REAL
THREAT.
>> HE DOES SEE IT AS A REAL
STRENGTH MATTERS.
DON'T EXPECT ANYBODY IN THE
LEFT IN THE MEDIA SEAN TO
GIVE HIM ANY CREDIT FOR
THIS.
AS WE SAW WITH REAGAN AND
CRUSHING SOVIET UNION.
THEY WENT AFTER REAGAN, NOT
THE SOVIET UNION.
JUST LIKE THEY DID, BY THE
WAY, WHEN THEY WENT AFTER
TRUMP WHEN HE WENT AFTER THE
NORTH KOREAN LEADER, A SWORN
ENEMY OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE LEFT IN THE MEDIA SPEND
INORDINATE AMOUNT OF TIME
FIGHTING FAKE ENEMIES,
INANIMATE STATUES.
I THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE
SERVINGS OF CROW GOING TO
SERVE TO THE MEDIA ON THE
LEFT.
THIS IS A MAJOR BREAK
THROUGH.
I WAS ACTUALLY ASTONISHED BY
THIS TONIGHT WHEN IT CAME
OUT I'M NOT SURPRISED BY
MUCH.
>> Sean: REMEMBER DURING THE
OLYMPICS, KIM JONG UN'S
SISTER MADE MIKE PENCE LOOK
BAD.
WHICH NEVER HAPPENED.
THAT WAS THE MEDIA'S
NARRATIVE.
OH MY GOD HE IS PROVOKING
WORLD WAR III.
HE SAID LITTLE ROCKET MAN.
ONE THING THAT IT SEEMS THAT
WE FORGET IS WE ARE THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
WE HAVE THE MEANEST,
TOUGHEST MILITARY ON THE
FACE OF THIS EARTH.
REMINDING DICTATORS THAT
THEY CANNOT INTIMIDATE US IS
NOT A BAD FOREIGN POLICY.
BUT, IF IT ENCOURAGES THEM
TO REACH OUT FOR PEACE, WE
OFFER OUR HAND IN PEACE
BECAUSE THE WORLD ULTIMATELY
IS BETTER OFF FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN.
IT'S NOT THAT COMPLICATED,
DR. GORKA.
>> IT'S NOT.
AND LET ME SHARE WITH YOU, I
WAS IN THE OVAL BY MYSELF
WITH THE PRESIDENT MAYBE
BACK IN MAY, AND HE JUST
LOOKED UP FROM HIS DESK AND
HE.
SAID:  I DO NOT WANT TO GO
TO WAR ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
HE UNDERSTANDS WHEN A THREAT
IS MADE.
AND HE LOVES OUR MILITARY
AND HE UNDERSTANDS THEM.
I TOOK 18 GREEN BERETS INTO
THE OVAL.
THE WAY HE CONNECTED WITH
THEM WAS INCREDIBLE.
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT
DIPLOMACY MEANS NOTHING
UNLESS YOU HAVE THE OPTION
FORCE TO BACK IT UP.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
FORGOTTEN FOR FAR TOO LONG
AND WHETHER IT'S A MOAB BOMB
IN AFGHANISTAN.
WHETHER IT'S CREWS MISSILES
IN SYRIA.
HE IS NOT ADVENTURIST BUT HE
WILL STAND UP TO EVIL AS WE
HAVE DONE MANY TIMES BEFORE.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW HOW THE
NEVER TRUMPERS ARE GOING TO
REACT.
HOW ARE THE TOM FREIDMANS?
HOW ARE THE SAD INDIVIDUALS
LIKE MAX GOING TO REACT NOW
WHEN DONALD TRUMP'S POLICIES
KEEP WINNING AND AS YOU
MENTIONED IT, I THINK THE
STEEL TARIFF IS PART OF THIS
DEAL.
>> Sean: ABSOLUTELY.
I WILL GET TO THAT LATER IN